les invités d'antenne 2010 donc comme
promis au début de ce journal les deux
jeunes premiers du cinéma français j'ai
nommé gérard lanvin et bernard giraudeau
tous deux pour des films qui sortent en
ce moment messieurs bonjour
installez vous vous l'avez très bien
descendu et remonter cet escalier bien
france roche on commence par qui gérard
lanvin bien oui on pourrait commencer
par gérard lanvin parce que les jeunes
premiers d'aujourd'hui sont plutôt des
bagarreurs voyez gérard lanvin lui le
prix du danger tir groupé ronde de nuit
ça castagne sec dans ses films et
bernard giraudeau qui était plus
romanesque
il était plus beau chic et 4 il était
attaché d'ambassade croque la vie
c'était un garçon charmant
alors lui aussi s'est mis à la
méchanceté dans rue barbare aussi alors
on va voir d'abord la bagarre et après
après la bagarre dont on regarde d'abord
donc un extrait du film
voilà on va d'abord voir un entre deux
rondes de nuit donc avec gérard lanvin
elie mitchell comme co vedette du film
m'ont lâché krine est mécano cepal un
mécano je crois les facteurs il a dû se
recycler ou alors il fait des heures sup
tu as raison c'est pour ça qu'on le voit
le soir la villa montsouris
sur sa moto exact sa motocyclette
buteur à votre gauche
les gones tubes dans le temps
effectivement géré alors c'est pas le
genre un amour de swann ça fait pas
vraiment dans la dans la nuance et tout
est à l'avenant dans le film non c'est
de bayard dans le film et puis le reste
l'enquète c'est sait les rapports entre
deux inspecteurs de police un peu
dépassé par la sphère qui sont en train
de l'essayer de régler c'est un film
d'humour un film un peu bande dessinée
c'est quoi ces deux décès de ces deux
policiers c'est starsky et hutch à la
française j'aimerais bien que ce soit
cela c'est un film qu'on a fait avec
mission parce qu'il a eu la bonne idée
de fin c'était le seul à ce moment-là
avoir pensé qu' eddy mitchell et moi on
pouvait faire quelque chose ensemble et
nous comme on l'avait pensé avant lui on
a signé ce film ensemble pour s'amuser
on va reparler ensuite dit rôle de jeune
premier et dont parlait tout à l'heure
france on va peut-être passer tout de
suite à l'extrait du second film alors
celui-ci qui déjà sorti alors là il a
déjà été happé voyez il a déjà le säntis
cool
il récupère bien alors là on va avoir un
effet donc de rue barbare avec christine
boisson
oui hagen imagine that n'est pas monté
ici par ses propres moyens
pourquoi c'est lui qui m'a mené c'est
par pure amitié baba les six doigts de
la main oh merde y'a pus marchessault
qu'on ait fera la paix qu est ce qu on
sait qu il a supplié de plus raté d'un
rien
paroles tu arrêtes tes conneries
officielle par amp et à pleurer
la supplier c'est exactement ce qu'ils
voulaient entendre de toi et lorsque
vous jouez une scène comme ça est ce que
vous prenez quand même un peu de coups
de temps en temps ou est-ce que vous
êtes tranquilles tout est réglé pour que
vous en sortiez sains et saufs ont géré
assez bien et je crois d'ailleurs c'est
daniel vérité qu'à régler les tiennent
depuis chez nous aussi
voilà dix ans que j'ai des coups de
pieds dire qu'il ya beaucoup de boxe
thaïlandaise donc avec bernard pierre
donnadieu bon allez sa tournée trois
jours la lyre de la faim ainsi minutes à
trois jours de tournage en jour et demi
et évidemment les coups de pied à la
figure c'est faut que ce soit très très
possible parce qu'il ya quand même la
ville et puis on est beaucoup moins
habile quand même si on n'est pas une
ceinture noire 4e dan dans l'évent là
bas même pas si sûr mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a un énorme travail à faire il
prend des coups on a pris des coups à un
pionnier en tout pas mal de coups quand
même la question vaut pour l'un ou pour
l'autre est ce que ces rôles de films
policiers sont plus agréables à jouer
que d'autres est ce que c'est quelque
chose de très agréable à jouer
est ce qu'on apprend l'impression de
revivre un peu des rêves d'enfants
lorsqu'on trouve ça plus que dans
d'autres
déjà je crois qu'on n'a pas du tout le
même film on connaît nos films c'est
bien du tout les milanais ont valu
quelque chose pareille
pour marie que je fais du cinéma toute
façon donc quand on propose un film
d'action comme ça ça me fait rigoler
mais c'est bon je vous cowboy un peu et
puis c'est important parce qu'on se
dépensent physiquement aussi un petit
peu ça évite de s'emmerder sur une
chaise avec une table un café en dix ans
il fuit en face tu veux boire du café ou
pas surtout d'intégration de la réponse
voilà surtout qu'on n'est pas sûr qu'ils
aient des cafés dans la naga fait en
plus mais non mais c'est important de
temps en temps de venir à ces films là
parce que ça défoule sait bien que c'est
marc giraud dos ça veut dire que moi et
physiquement je suis comme je suis comme
j'ai envie de m'amuser j'ai envie de
donner du plaisir j'ai envie d'avoir du
plaisir en toute chose
bon il se trouve que le pourvoi la
première fois moi dans ce film j'avais
des choses physiques à faire mais ça
fait un moment déjà que je crois qu'il
peut les arts martiaux
donc j'ai travaillé la boxe thaïlandaise
pour ça mais finalement mon cas de la
pièce que je joue en voilà pour
saint-martin je vais faire d'alpinisme
on s'amuse mais c'est un hasard pur
hasard parce que dans quelques temps je
vais tourner alors une autre
caractéristique des nouveaux jeune
premier de la génération 30 ans ce qui
ne se contente pas de se battre et de se
taire ils se mêlent de leurs films et se
cherche des scénarios et se cherche des
rôles et vous deux vous discutez avec
vos metteur en scène de vos personnages
non je crois que c'est vrai déjà avec
nous mettant en scène est ce qu'il ya de
plus vrai encore ces consciences surtout
poteau d'ici peu il me faire et que ça
fait un moment qu'on cherche bon c'est
pas si simple de trouver un scénario
alors les producteurs sont prêts c'est
vrai ils sont pas ils ont bien envie
qu'on travaille tous les sens mais c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile de trouver
deux personnages l'idée l'idée de base
qu'ils soient très costaud parce que
nous on se connaît bien c'est même bien
on y travaille ensemble on se marre bien
on sait qu'on va s'amuser très fort et
qu'on va amuser les gens c'est vrai on
sait peu son plaisir quand je parlais il
ya bernard giraudeau jardin on parlait
tout à l'heure des jeunes promis en
commençant y ait une évolution du
physique de jeune premier dans le cinéma
par exemple si on remonte à jean gabin
jean paul belmondo ou alain delon qui
sont tout de même d'une génération au
dessus de la vôtre se tait des physiques
j'allais dire presque parfait
aujourd'hui le jeune premier n'est pas
forcément quelqu'un qui a un physique
presque parfait soit peu musculairement
ou physiquement le visage tout parce
qu'une fois sa ligne en ce qui nous
concerne nous on est très bien on est
pas mal
franchement franchement on est bien
problème c'est qu'on a du bol parce que
y'a pas jean gabin encore belmondo delon
espère bien falloir travailler aussi
avec un accent bernard giraudeau lui
pense à l'avenir parce qu'il fait des
courts métrages déjà alors on va
peut-être apprendre que gérard lanvin
écrit des scénarios si vous la prenez
vous me lirez l'avoir moi j'ai créé un
petit peu je sais de réécrire un peu mes
textes parce que le problème c'est que
au départ d'un film tout le monde est
d'accord
fillon en personne au fur et à mesure du
film y en a qu'un qui bossent et celui
qui fait le film et ibos pour lui c'est
à dire ils bossent pour faire son film
c'est là où il ya un problème tout d'un
coup on se dit tiens moi je voudrais le
faire pour les gens et a parfois le
réalisateur s'enferme dans sa propre
exactement donc ça fait que
effectivement il faudrait prendre la
faire à la base et puis ne plus quitter
ne plus quitter du tout est travaillé on
sait ce que les acteurs de votre
génération demande a plus participé
d'une manière générale avec le
réalisateur ou bien ça dépend du
réalisateur si c'est un grand on se tait
on tourne et puis si c'est un autre
match participe énormément je peux pas
faire autrement avec gilles béhat ça a
été ça a été formidable j'ai travaillé
deux mois avant avec lui je suis allé
travailler que vautrin cav est
l'adaptation et avec gilles moi j'allais
improvisé des siennes comme ça pour me
marier une lise et on a travaillé en
collaboration deux mois avant le
tournage tout le tour ne faut pas faire
autrement ça ne m'intéresse pas de faire
du cinéma si je peux pas savoir comment
jean françois robin est clair le film
comment le caméraman tient seule caméra
j'ai envie de tout savoir sur un
tournage ça m'emmerde d'arrivée avec mon
texte sur rasoir je la ferai jamais été
de me dire on dit mais là tu vas là et
tu fais ça ne veut plus rien dire
il faut qu'on participe à ce que les
personnages qu'on on s'investit
énormément dans ce personnage on s'y
amuse beaucoup mais pour s'amuser ou sam
jusqu'au bout avec la technique c'est à
dire que ça quand on est au théâtre on a
les spectateurs maintenant quand elle
est au cinéma on à la caméra numérique
risque de nous bouffer ont promis de se
faire bouffer plaqué berne envie de
jouer avec l environnement
voilà ça nous énerve alors en rester là
pour que ça tourne mal et vous remercier
le studio en tout cas merci d'être venu
pour ces deux films dont je rappelle le
titre
l'unss et rhubarbe à qui est déjà sortie
avec bernard giraudeau et l'autre qui
sort demain
exactement je crois en france avec
gérard lanvin eddy mitchell qui lui
s'appelle rendu de nuit